a couple other questions for you
spiral do you have anything to do with
that no I have not had anything to do
with the soar films for quite a while
obviously I'm still friends with a lot
of the people involved yeah but I've
really taken a back seat it's a strange
thing to sort of create a movie and then
watch it go off into the wilderness
without you and well also with Chris
Rock and Sam Jackson what was your first
reaction when you heard that's the
direction the franchise what's going
I'll tell you I was on a location scout
for this movie and I got a phone call
from one of the guys at Lionsgate who's
a friend of mine and when he told me
about Chris Rock I thought back to a
couple of years ago I was at a film
festival party at the Palm Springs Film
Festival and my agent much to my horror
pushed me towards Chris Rock and was
like say hi to Chris I think I said
something lame like I'm a big fan and he
hears that hundred times a day so he was
like okay and as he was walking away his
agent said to him that guy rode saw and
he like stopped in his tracks came back
and was like you wrote saw and suddenly
he was super interested and he said to
me I would love to make a soar film and
I thought it was just something that you
say in a party you know like hey I'd
love to dye my hair pink too you just
say it because the person's come pink
hair you don't wanna make them feel bad
turns out he was serious that was not
that was not an offhand thing that he
said he really did want to make a soar
film so that was the first thing I
thought about when I heard the news was
Wow Chris Rock wasn't joking